did you guys watch the fights this
weekend
i watched uh the
camaro fight pretty awesome that was
great yeah that was great yeah right
he's unstoppable yeah
star wars [ __ ] yo colby did his thing
though i thought after the second round
he was done come on strong but that
[ __ ] fought dude i think he won
two rounds at least yeah i think it was
i think it was three two three two is
what i would have thought but i think
you could probably give that second
round make it like a ten eight eight
rounds yeah cause he got him twice yeah
i mean i thought he was it was done
after that second round yeah i thought
if it was 10 more seconds is over yeah
yeah it would have been yeah it was
close but to do that and then win two
out of the next three rounds is pretty
[ __ ] impressive
both of them want this is what i love
about ufc you could lose and win
like both of them law well sorry
michael chandler and
um
colby covington lost their fights
neither of their stock went down per se
yeah because we watch the fights because
of entertainment purposes yeah right
we're like i just want to be entertained
so who's going to entertain me the most
yeah fight of the night that's all i
want that's right yeah that's who really
wins and chandler was tweeting today
with or yesterday with conor mcgregor
and he's like 20 22 a picture of conor
mcgregor after a loss he's calling out
right one of the biggest names in the
division after a loss and then conor
goes i think we'll definitely do that
later on down the line great fight mate
yeah
in boxing you lose you don't get to call
people out right you don't get to say
who the next fight is none of that [ __ ]
yeah right but in mma if you are
entertaining you hold the [ __ ] cards
nate diaz holds the [ __ ] cards
because he's entertaining doesn't matter
he lost his last fight leon edwards the
guy he fought holds no cards yeah can't
call out nobody you think we can
rationalize it easier because ufc has so
many different like components to it
yeah i mean like if you're up against
like a wrestler but you're an amazing
striker and you just get like locked out
like armbar in the first round it's like
all right yeah i mean it's a bad matchup
blah blah blah whereas with boxing it's
like you throw punches you get punched
like that's all you do so if you get
knocked out you got punched more than
the other guy like it's one single thing
yeah so it's like a single metric
whereas like with mma there's so many
different variables into a fight where
you're like oh well you know technically
like you can rationalize a loss a lot
easier yeah especially decision loss
right exactly like
with a decision loss to nate
you almost look at it like
if it kept going he might got him right
even with colby i don't think if it kept
going that kamar would have lost still
but
you could he you could make the argument
like colby was coming on right as the
rounds went off yeah yeah and so you're
like if this was on the street because i
think we view it as a street fight like
if this was on the street
yeah
[ __ ] like maybe if they just kept fight
there's no rounds maybe if they kept
fighting right you would have got gas
and that would have been it it would
have been it but then you could also say
maybe in the second round camaro would
have just finished him but yeah there's
that i think uh nate diaz even said that
after uh his loss to leon edwards like
in the fifth round remember he rocked
him right and he like staggered him he
was dude if this is a street fight it's
over it's like yeah you're wobbling
around you got saved by the bell yeah
now it's still your job to knock that
[ __ ] out yeah but yeah there's
something different about the sport it's
like provide entertainment and i think
michael chandler in his fight realized
he wasn't going to beat gaichi and i
think he tried to win the night
just put on the best show i think there
was a moment where he started like
playing to the crowd more and gait she's
still landing but he's able to take the
shots maybe gage is a little bit tired
just his legs starting to get chewed up
but he's really playing into the crowd
like inviting him in and going like i
think i saw that moment on twitter when
like he's getting [ __ ] rocked in the
face and he just charges back at him and
like let's go and shit'll make you like
somebody yeah chandler's a smart guy
like he really understands the marketing
aspect of ufc he's just went from i
think it was like bellator and now he's
there's a
huge difference in talent from bellator
to ufc right like massive like ufc has
really monopolized all the best fighters
right and it is a dip when you go into
the other promotions so that's why you
see these guys struggle when they play
they're in the ufc i mean ben askren was
a dominant fighter then goes into the
ufc
and he struggles man yeah he gets worked
and uh so there is a big difference so
like i think chandler is realizing that
you know
and he had an amazing first fight
against like dan hooker but then after
that
you know charles oliveira knocks him out
yeah right and then justin gaichi it was
a great fight but justin justin
dominated yeah outside of the first
round
and but he understands listen i can i
can get a big payday again
as long as i just make this loss
entertaining yeah so i'm gonna bleed i'm
gonna swing i'm gonna make it look crazy
i'm gonna be out there and you know what
i get [ __ ] paid but if i get finished
one at least i can finish in an exciting
way but if i don't get finished i think
i'm good maybe he lost a little bit even
if you get finished though didn't
whitaker get finished by izzy and then
he's coming back and he's getting like
they might have a rematch he just built
his name back up he had to build his
name back up but that next fight with
whitaker was almost like uh he was back
in a contender situation yeah
and like he won a few of those fights
right and he won them in like uh really
impressive fashion
and because of that it was like okay
he's the next line and then he had to
wait for izzy to basically clean out the
division
and that's kind of what's left and then
you're back yeah and i like i like
robert whitaker as a fighter like he's a
really good fighter i don't think the
ufc likes him
in other words like i think they like
stars yeah he's just not yeah like the
ufc loves mike perry just he's not good
enough yeah to fight the guys in ufc but
like if mike perry
was as good as robert whittaker yeah
give him whatever he wants [ __ ]
superstar yeah like they like the
characters they like the stars they like
colby colby was talking about this yeah
he was about i heard a crazy story like
colby was about to get cut no matter win
or loss yeah in his fight when he went
to brazil yeah he went to brazil to
fight uh maybe damien maya or something
like that somebody's in brazil
win or lost they said they're cutting
him they just don't like his character
or whatever
afterwards he records that promo where
he's like brazil i own you this that the
other it might even have been after
conor did the i own brazil thing okay
but he records that promo the promo goes
so viral ufc can't let him go
because there's already so much free
marketing yeah like imagine you got 10
million impressions you literally go to
your marketing department you go what
would it cost us to get 10 million
impressions yeah and they go uh three
hundred thousand dollars yeah
we go okay why don't we just keep him
for one more 300 fight and 300 thousand
dollar fight and then we got it for free
yeah or we sign him for three more it's
like you have to create the buzz yeah
you know and
it's so funny you see the the fighters
understand this and then just start to
lean into it right and there's very few
fighters in the ufc that just go hey man
i just come to fight i don't want to
deal with the politics and all that [ __ ]
it's like even the dagestani guys yeah
right the dagger saying you guys are the
most respectful like muslim you know we
have to respect the sport respect this
you mean khabib is all out here like why
do we even need ring girls what's the
point of this i mean like now these
young dagger standing [ __ ] yeah
hey i eat everybody
yeah division is mine playing to the
lore like i wrestled bears bro
like we all wrestle bears like my dad's
a bear my mom's a favorite like i'm a
bear bro 100
so it's it's really interesting how like
you can get people to behave in a
certain way just by reward yeah you
don't even have to tell them to do it
they'll see the other people being
rewarded for the behavior and they'll
just naturally fall yeah because you
have to for survival yeah it's
pay-per-view we gotta you gotta be worth
paying for it mm-hmm and if you're not
what are we doing yep yeah fighting
[ __ ] that's a very small
percentage of people who just want to
see fights yeah i have to be emotionally
invested to watch people beat the [ __ ]
out of each other i have to have a
rooting interest yeah it's so true a
fight for me as a very much a casual
when i don't know the for the
personalities involved i have no
interest you need cardinals or carnage i
need carnage and even then i'm like i
don't even hate one of these guys he's
getting the [ __ ] kept both of them
getting the [ __ ] out of each other but
if i don't like one of the guys or i
really like one of the guys do what you
got to do man yeah so i think you need
to build up persona
really well liked and or hated izzy
loved and hated you gotta watch it yeah
[Music]
yeah
what was what was your favorite fight on
the card
probably gaechi versus chandler yeah i
mean gaichi is just such a fascinating
guy the way that he fights is just
unbelievable what do you mean just the
amount of risk he takes oh yeah like he
sits there in the pocket he puts himself
in harm's way on purpose stays exposed
yeah he he he has the skill to not yeah
right like he could be a way less
interesting fighter yeah like but he
chooses to stay in the zone
and
he counters well he'll slip but he
understands he's gonna get cracked and
he gets cracked he gets wobbled he gets
hurt stays in there yeah
and basically says the same thing
everything i'm going to take them into
deep water i'm going to drown them and
that's what the [ __ ] he did yeah and
michael chandler didn't drown but he
took him into deep water like chandler
had gaichi [ __ ] hurt yeah it looked
like he almost had him out of there in
the first right
just like which uh charles oliveira
and then he couldn't get it down the
first and then second
geisha came on strong those leg kicks
are just [ __ ] crazy i just love
watching the guy fight i'll just keep
watching him fight and i think he's
fighting for the belt next charles
oliveira or dustin pouria and then um
we're gonna see what happens man do you
think kamaru they're saying he might be
the greatest pound for pound
ever i think some people are saying
they're comparing them to uh they were
saying um welterweight welterweight i
saw some people saying he has a shot at
being i mean look you look at the
numbers it's impressive yeah i mean it's
just it's really impressive he's
dominant man i think he's only lost one
i thought it was like maybe his first it
was like his first fight i think her
second fight something like that yeah so
it's unbelievable he just keeps getting
better like the striking
that's what i was going to say it seems
like he keeps getting better yeah it
seems like he just keeps getting better
yeah yeah as of now they're saying that
if leon edwards is going to fight
mazvidal december 11th yeah so you think
if leon edwards beats mazvid out she
should yeah that's but that would be the
next camaro fight that could be the next
camaro fight or you make
or you make uh colby fight maz vidal or
something like that i mean i don't know
mozville probably needs a win
you know what i mean like mazda is lost
he's still like sometimes but it's leon
edwards 19 and three against
vidal 35 and 15. yeah yeah yeah leon
should win that fight but there's like
some good back you know story to that
fight i mean like mazvidal punched him
in backstage oh yeah oh [ __ ] yeah so it
was like there's like fun build-up to
that fight and then mas vidal can
promote the [ __ ] out of a fight he knows
how to do it he's an interesting guy but
if he loses again we're looking at like
a few losses in a row and then i don't
know
i don't i don't know i just i'm just
curious i'm curious to see who colby
fights next yeah i was wondering that
had a lot of heart man and yeah i think
he won people over at the end
with the the sign of respect between
both of them i think even people who
hated colby were like oh that was cool
it was a cool moment yeah people like to
see heart yeah they like to see someone
get their ass [ __ ] kicked and keep on
going yeah you know he did really i mean
that's really what rocky is all about
right yeah the whole movie is based on
this guy who gets his ass kicked and
then just keeps on going yeah and i
think there's something relatable that
maybe in life mostly it's a metaphor for
life life is mostly getting your ass
kicked yeah and then you just keep going
and you you should win if you keep going
yeah but yeah what a [ __ ] card man it
was just unbelievable and then canelo
obviously fought yeah and uh
you know canelo is just dominant did
what we all thought he was going to do
yeah but plant was the plan was no
slouch right plain was nasty no good
he's good but canelo's just on a
different level and he's fighting so far
above his weight class like canelo's
just making it hard for himself yeah you
know canelo started fighting i think at
154 pounds i think he fought uh floyd at
155 floyd dominated him right but like
that's that will eventually be floyd's
greatest victory
what's really interesting happening
right now with like floyd and canelo is
that the greater canelo gets in terms of
his legacy yeah the greater that victory
that flawless victory that floyd had
over canelo becomes that was the most
again don't know much i saw
i know floyd's last eight nine fights
that was the most impressive one yeah
like i've watched everyone from de la
hoya on that was the one where i was
like god damn this is a clinic yeah but
canelo wasn't nearly the same fighter he
is now right
so they say i mean it seems like he's on
a different level yeah i think that's
what happens when you fight floyd
when you fight everyone else you seem
like you're on a different level when
you're fair enough but triple g so this
is this is what i was wondering about
canelo's plays in history loses to floyd
triple g people thought he lost the
first and second fight right
debatable
then they had the trilogy and then he
beat his ass pretty pretty handling the
third time right i mean all of them are
debatable so i thought that the first
one was really close and it could have
gone triple g okay i think the second
one people thought that could have been
canelo but they're both debatable okay
but he won both of them but then he has
a steroid scandal so like this is a guy
who it seems like
very far outside he's going for one of
the greatest ever how much is all that
stuff early on hurt him
just the steroids are the most i think
what hurts him is that there's this we
don't know his personality that much and
he just doesn't speak english so he
doesn't like resonate to the american
people and just boxing is on the decline
we're just not that interested in it
right like if canelo was an mma fighter
fighting in the ufc and he was this
dominant yeah this would be a different
story yeah i mean we're talking about
global superstar right and right now
because there's not that much interest
in boxing there's not a lot of american
boxers that we're you know uh super
uh i don't know how to say it like uh
just engaged by you know like they don't
have a promotional apparatus like the
ufc ufc is constantly putting out these
[ __ ] crazy promo clips that make
every fighter on the roster no matter
how many losses they have look like the
greatest fighter in history right so
you're just getting charged up
constantly like the wbc who was one of
the sanctioning parties for boxing is
not doing that with its boxers right
there's no promo coming out with boxers
yeah unless you're a boxer you put your
own promo out and if they're doing it it
usually sucks yeah you need the best
editors in the world ufc is hiring the
best editors in the world to make that
[ __ ] look incredible and it gets you
gassed up right and the only time that
happens with boxers is if they're
fighting for hbo yeah hbo or showtime or
whatever one of these pay-per-view
outlets is but like
those pay-per-view outlets don't own the
boxer right so they have no vested
interest in making that boxer big
they're just doing these one-off things
yeah like maybe you have a deal with
showtime maybe you have a two-fight deal
but the ufc owns these [ __ ] so
they're like if i own them i'm gonna
make them as big as possible so i can
make as much money on them as possible
right right like if i am paying them a
guaranteed salary
no matter how popular they are this is
their guaranteed salary i might as well
make them more popular so that i get
that difference in income yeah
right if i make them a hundred thousand
dollars popular and i'm paying them a
hundred thousand dollars i break even
this was pointless right but if i have a
hundred thousand dollar fighter a guy
who i'm paying a hundred thousand
dollars a fight and they have a 500 000
interest right i just made 400 000 yeah
yeah
get to cooking up clips yeah
it's like the uh
it's more exploitative but it might be
better for the fighter in the long run
it's
that's the thing it's way better for the
fighter because you build your career
out yeah like if i'm a fighter i'm going
with the ufc even if they pay less it's
like netflix it's like everybody who's
doing netflix specials outside of dave
chappelle is accepting less money to be
on netflix and netflix knows that
right because that's the golden goose
yeah right so that you go okay i'll do
it for far less than i would do on some
other platform but ideally i get all
these eyeballs and then people want to
see me on the road they want to see me
do these other things right
you build your career that way there are
fighters that fight the ufc you let the
ufc build the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you
even if you don't win go fight in a
lesser promotion for more money you've
become famous yeah the ufc made you
famous
you try to sell promotional stuff like
there's a couple fighters who actually
get it they're like listen i don't make
that much fighting for ufc but they made
me famous or gave me the opportunity to
become famous and then i can sell all
these other things sponsorships like
crazy
ufc is not taking their sponsorship yeah
you got a cbd company giving you money
get that money go go go ahead izzy got a
cbd sponsor go ahead boom sean
o'malley's doing it yeah is he got tons
it's like use the opportunity use the
platform use the leverage because no
other promotional company knows how to
promote fighters like this yeah now you
could always fight for more you know
even wages that kind of [ __ ] like go for
it i'm not telling you not to right but
also recognize what you got yeah if you
got in this game to only be a fighter
and not do any promo and not entertain
you got in the wrong game you should
stay in the olympics yeah like the
olympics is for you just win and you
don't have to bring anything fun or
fancy now you're in entertainment yeah
some of the guys know it and those
[ __ ] get paid yeah nobody
buying your [ __ ] pay-per-view because
i'm not spending 50 because you're
technical
yes so you're good at [ __ ] grapples i
don't care yeah i couldn't care less
yeah make me like you or make me hate
you that's
it man